hey everyone it's Michael BOS from order
flows.com and welcome to the orderflows
market analysis for Friday June 9 2017
Now Stocks were mixed on the day with
the Dow posted a a marginal weekly gain
of about like
0.3% and the big uh the big loser on the
week was oil oil had a very bad week it
was down about 4% just under 46 bucks
and the markets really had no reaction
at least the equity markets I mean
currency Market it's had a reaction to
the uh UK election general election
where the conservatives who instead of
expanding their majority lost their M
majority so anyway that said let's jump
into it this is uh my disclaimer again I
I go through the disclaimer because you
know again you know for everybody that's
coming to these videos you know I want
you to realize trading is risky this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
they should put something else in there
saying um you know my results may not be
your results your results may not be the
guy next to you their results the uh
tools used in this presentation are the
order flows Trader volume footprint
chart and I talk a bit about the Delta
scalper indicator so you know let's uh
let's Jump Right In Here first I'll talk
about the uh snps let me just find the
chart okay so this is the uh September
S&P and you know even though you know we
ended the day up a little bit we did
have a very big range it was about a 30
point range we had a high of 43 a half I
think our low was what 12 uh 12 A2 yeah
12 and A2 here um
but you know at the
High I want to say you don't really have
much in the order flow but uh you know
it took a while to put in this High it
took about an hour for this bar to form
this bar finished at 924 these are 10
range this is a 10 range chart and then
um took about an hour put in some very
good volume 118,000 contracts you can
see a lot of volume here 13,000 9,000
9,000 here 10,000 10,000 11,000 um you
know and when I see a bar sort of you
know at a high of the day sort of
spinning around like that I I have a
feeling though it it could possibly be
the high of the day now there was
nothing in terms of um ratios there's
nothing in terms of Divergence in the
bar afterwards you do have a bearish
ratio here and more importantly you know
the one thing that
was I remember looking at this thinking
is this going to be the high and even
though there's nothing in in terms of
ratio Divergence I'm going to watch the
point of control I ideally I'd like this
point of control to be a little bit
higher but you know it's coming in here
at uh 41 and 3/4 next bar point of
control coming in at 41 next bar 40 and
A2 so you know I I see we're starting to
move off the high lower highs lower lows
but more importantly lower point of
controls and we start moving down down
down
down um down down down you get down here
to 33 and a half you still got negative
Delta you know it's minus 81 it's kind
of neutral in that sense then you get
this bar here you got the Delta scalper
kicking off but again it's it's still a
uh it's still a red bar so I'm not
looking to take any buys um on on a
candle that can't even turn green and go
up so you know we still work our way
down we're still looking for you know
determining are we going to be coming
into a low making a new low or what now
you know there's nothing really in the
order flow telling you to get long at
the same time you know we we are
trending lower um you know on on a
pure um price action so to speak uh
activity you know lower high high and
lower lows lower point of controls you
know it's telling you the trend is uh
trend is going down down down we get
down to the low make new lows you do
have a Divergence here and you don't
have a ratio okay so again I'm not yet
convinced that this is going to be our
low for the day yet but we get down here
at our low of the day 242 a half and
what do you got you got a Divergence you
got a ratio again I talk about these
things every day you know if you're not
using ratios and Divergence you know I
said if you just buy buy my software you
know and only look for this setup a
ratio with a Divergence you know it's
worth it it's worth it you know I talk
about a lot of other setups but again
you if there's only one setup you can
trade with it's this one a ratio with a
Divergence and what happens the market
starts rallying you know you got higher
highs higher lows higher point of
controls and next bar you even have a a
bullish um ratio and you know the other
thing that that's very telling is you
know we're coming down here and you just
see these Deltas yeah I mean they're
negative you know - 900 - 173 - 2800
then you get the spot here with positive
1700 then comes right back with a small
Delta 386 and then negative again 1273
then you get down here 1265 positive
Delta here boom
4,831 it's your strongest positive Delta
pretty much of the day and it's almost
your in your absolute well since I mean
is stronger than this one but you know
in an absolute sense since you hit the
high back here at at 1023 it's your
strongest Delta one way or the other
4831 so again you know this is
information that's in the order flow the
Delta is the difference between the net
buying on the offer versus the Net
selling on the offer so I know at this
point you know buying is solid
legitimate buying is coming into this
market and that's what you want to see
if you're going to pull up from a
low you know you know forget that you
got the ratio with the Divergence you
know say you don't have it you know and
you see a bar like this very strong
positive Delta that's a clue right may
not be enough by itself but you know
really the sign is here with the ratio
and the Divergence and this is
confirming to you in the next bar that
yeah we are getting the buying coming in
from this low people are accepting this
as being the low and being aggressive
saying I got to get in you know
we're putting in our low here I got to
start buying it you know this is price
is cheap and I'm looking for the rally
and we go up you mean we Rally from 162
all the way up into the 20s and then we
go higher higher higher um you come off
a little bit and you know we end the day
marginally higher but still you know
there a big range day even though you
look at the net change you know just
look at the newspaper and see oh it was
um uh you know it was up a little bit
but then you know when you break it down
and you look at the actual Market
activity you see that wow you know you
had a big range and then there were some
um decent trades to be taken there all
right then next market I'll talk about
is the five years okay five years were
were very interesting I I like five
years because you know they're slow
moving market and when they start
trending if you get yourself on the
right side of the trend it can be very
rewarding so about 8:30 we come into
this low we got a ratio with a
Divergence I just showed you a ratio
with the Divergence on the snps on the
10 range chart now you got it again in
the five years now we're just going
sideways though point of control is sort
of basically lined up you come down
within a tick of the low and then you
start rallying up I mean this was a slow
one right this is 8:30 2 10:00 you're
still around you know around your entry
price it is until after 10:00 that you
really put in a nice rally but again
there's no reason to be getting short
down here you have reason to be buying
right here and the market just you know
eventually makes its move but you know
this was a slow one that's going to test
your patience as you you see point of
controls lining up which is a sign of a
market going sideways but still no
reason to be um getting short or getting
necessarily getting out of your position
I mean the only thing that would make me
want to get out of the position is just
the time it's just taken a long time and
before it made its
move all right the next market I'll talk
about is uh crude oil and again you know
crude oil was the big uh Loser on the
week was down um down about four four
bucks or sorry 4% and uh you know
there's still some interesting things
here in the crude uh we did have some
good movement as well here you got 7:30
you got the swing low and you're coming
down you know this was a nice little
buying opportunity if you're just
reading the Delta you're coming in on
weakening Delta Delta starts positive uh
gets strong here very similar to uh the
S&P on the Delta side um starts turning
around and you get the big Delta push
right here we do pop up um here you get
the Delta surge given a
sell comes off to this new swing low
Delta surge given a buy and you know you
do pop up a
bit um come back down a little bit later
make new highs um here you just have a
ratio with a imbalance right on the top
of the bar doesn't react yeah it comes
off a little bit um again I I find these
imbalances at the highs as small uh
small small move opportunities again I'm
not looking for this Market to sell off
from this High um to new lows or
anything but rather over the next couple
bars make a little bit of a move lower
we do start making some new highs up
here we get up here just off this High
uh we hit the high next dogee with the
Delta scalper yeah
and dogee candles I just find generally
are neutral in terms of order flow so
I'm not really like I don't really like
to take
signals on dogee candles when they
appear get up here you got new high
nothing in the order flow up here you
don't have a ratio don't have a
Divergence um but you do start coming
off regardless and a little bit later or
oh that was it for the day
um nothing else there sorry I thinking
of some other Market but really the the
interesting thing was this morning the
730 move here the way it was coming down
like that this you know just again
reading the Delta it's kind of
lightening up turning positive turning
nice and strong here and you get a nice
rally there okay so uh the next market
I'll talk about is japen
and in the morning you had this nice uh
selloff you got stacked inbalance you
know at 749 around the 9050 area um a
little bit later 9040 area you get
another stacked inbalance 9035 area get
another stacked inbalance and you hit
this this spot right here um 90 uh was
that 9028 you got 950 contracts on the
bid there you know for uh Japanese y or
for any currency you that is a that is a
big big number you can see the Delta
quite it just bulges out minus 1291
that's that's quite strong um you know
it's an imbalance you know the next bar
again imbalance you know imagine you
know just try and think in your head
close your eyes you know you're not I'm
not showing you a dome but you know when
when it's trading there 9028 you know it
keeps it I I don't know if it was
showing the whole size most likely it
was Iceberg and you know Traders are
there they're trying to get it lower
lower lower um trying to break it
through 9028 they finally get it through
9028 and it just trades off one two
three ticks lower and then what happens
you know all these people that are
selling it right are are thinking hey
you know if we get past this 28
level you know the floodgates could open
and maybe we'll get trade down to 20 but
they get past the 28 level finally
everyone and their brothers selling it
um you know trying to get it lower but I
mean it's a currency so sometimes you do
get these outsized uh outsized volume
numbers because you know sometimes maybe
someone's working something against a
cash position or who knows what but
anyway you know the the the the local
Trader the smaller Traders you know
they're thinking hey you know there's
some support here I got to get past this
break down the support maybe trigger
some stops here and get the market to go
down and it doesn't it comes back it
just hangs around here gets three ticks
lower and then you see all these people
that were selling it here you know the
Smart Ones thinking I got to cover
it we're not going lower you you got
this buying in balance here7 9 um you
know people are starting to scramble
they're covering it they're covering it
you know 58 imbalance up here 110 and so
the market it pops back up right so all
these people that were selling it in
here hoping the market can go lower
realizing it's not going lower you know
people are covering it back at a at a
higher price and you know the market
eventually starts rallying back up you
know why
because there there's nothing here that
they could trigger um you know other
time frame Traders aren't coming into
the market trying to push the market
lower you know this push it got pushed
lower yes by three ticks but there was
no follow through selling you know from
uh longer time frame
Traders you know then the market makes
its move back up back up back up this is
the Delta surge here giv a nice Buy
Signal um again you get up you know
there really wasn't a whole lot you know
this this High I thought was interesting
here at uh just at at 2:00 but again
it's 2:00 on a Friday afternoon I'm not
interested in trading currencies even
though this is a nice sell signal here
you got a nice ratio um right at the
swing high but again I'm I'm not
interested at at at 2:00 on a Friday
afternoon in in trading a currency a lot
of cash traders already closed their
books for the
day okay just really quick this is uh
September buns buns is the German 10year
interest rate contract and again you
know I've spent a lot of time talking
about ratios with
Divergence and how it can make you money
so I'll give you an example buns uh they
open up about uh 2: a.m. Chicago time
two you know so if you got a job during
the day you could easily trade buns you
know in the morning before you go to
work here's a nice example 2:58 a.m.
Chicago time got a ratio with Divergence
you rally up from your low to your high
got a ratio up here no Divergence um so
it's not really a good shorting
opportunity um Delta scul gives you a
buy but it's a buy going into the high
you know do you want to take it I prefer
to take buys off the lows rather than
off the highs um here you got Delta
scoper giving you a buy off the low um
it goes up next bar goes up comes back
in over the third bar test the low where
you have the Delta scalper kicking off
rallies back up to the high here you got
a Divergence no ratio Delta scalper next
bar comes off U you know several ticks
so goes from 04 down to uh 9
996 rallies back up starts coming back
down another Delta scalper cell here you
it's a little bit close to the low but
at this point it's a tight range 16510
to uh
16490 but uh anyway a little bit later
here you get a new low and a Divergence
this is also the price rejector but a
low with a Divergence what happens this
one fails okay not every time it's going
to be a winner you know I showed you
earlier you went from your low to your
high that was a nice trade here you got
one and it doesn't work it fails it
comes right back with a bearish ratio in
the next bar which is not a good sign
that the trade's going to work out I
mean you know just because you get into
a trade don't don't either let it go to
your profit Target or your stop level
you know if you're reading the order
flow and you see what's happening in the
market is act is negative in this case
you know you you get into the trade on a
very bullish setup but then immediately
afterwards you got a bearish um number a
bearish bar you know be careful and and
this one it doesn't work then you get
down here Delta scalper
ratio with Divergence and what happens
Market goes sideways you hit the same
level again ratio with Divergence and
now what's happening Market's starting
to Rally you go from your low 16474
realistically you're probably getting in
around 78 79 and what does it do it just
rallies keeps rallying you know what
what what's the entry you know 80 maybe
worst case scenario it as it do it comes
right up within a few ticks of your high
of the day um this time it's already
2:00 block but you know on this move up
is there any reason to be getting short
no getting out of this trade no I mean
initially here you might be a little bit
hesitant because yeah maybe you got out
you know you got Delta scalper you got
ratio you got
Divergence you know it's giving you a
buy but it's coming right back down you
know with a negative sign but then again
it's giving you the ratio with
Divergence here get in it's not giving
you any negative sign here in this next
bar that you know be careful and you
round you got higher highs higher lows
point of controls all going up you know
is reacting the way you want it to react
so you know while you had you know
basically three trades we'll call it
four one was basically you know break a
scratch here maybe you lost a tick this
trade here you lost you know maybe four
or five ticks this first
trade you know early in the morning you
went from your low to your high wasn't a
great move you're talking 16490 up to
16502 was a 12o range but still you know
it gave you something it it's giv you
you know from 94 all the way up to you
know up to the high so maybe you could
have got you know at least six ticks out
of there so you know this first trade
and the second trade which was a loss
you know maybe you you're break even at
this point this trade I don't know if
you would have gotten out here maybe
maybe not but definitely you should get
on board for this trade and this is you
know so at this point you're sort of at
break even maybe down a tick you know
maybe up two ticks who knows but this
next trade you know this is the one you
know from 16480 worst case scenario all
the way up to you know 165 even at least
at a minimum hopefully but at least 20
ticks on that on that trade so again
it's you know trading is about being in
the game you know you you can't win it
unless you're in it all right you can
sit here and Monday Morning Quarterback
it all all you want and it's easy but
again you know I know I know some people
that would have taken this trade then
lost on it and think oh you know I'm I'm
not going to take the next I want to see
it work and then here it just sort of
goes sideways and you know just oh you
know this one was borderline it didn't
work and then they miss this trade you
know you miss it you know I mean you
shouldn't be trading fully leveraged
that you have one loss and it just wipes
you out for trading till you put more
money in your account you know trade
with enough money in your account that
you can take you know a loss two losses
three losses in a row and keep on going
you know I mean it's trading in some
respects is a numbers game you know you
you got to you got to put in the amount
of Trades to get uh to get the winners
but I mean if if you're not trading for
whatever reason you know there
psychologically or you don't have the
money you know in in your account to
sustain one or two losses then it's
going to be difficult that when a good
trade comes
around you're not there to participate
in it
so you know that that's it for the day
um so thanks for watching this um to
learn more about training software I Us
in this
presentation and how you can profit from
order order flow visit my website
orderflows
docomo when I can at least you know I
said even if you don't buy my software
at least you can learn something about
order flow and trading in general so
thanks everyone and bye-bye